we have a voicemail number 219 to david
p the egg man weighing in on Keurig gate
after producer Pat revealed that he uses
Keurig pods it really shook the world
numerous reddit threads about this and
the egg man we had to bleep a number of
swears off of this but here's the egg
man's position hey Dave I guess Pat
didn't get the memo that if you use a
Keurig or bring that up he's going to
get home and beat up and abused dude man
my wife and I are driving the doctor you
have today just listen to Pakman show
you know the podcast right talking about
your coffee in the background soon has
passed it I guess use occurred my wife
church to meet her jaw drops with a lie
hahaha it's on firm Pat he didn't get
the memo holy the vegan that uses
occurred I think he let it slip that he
puts his own fresh coffee there he
doesn't waste a little so I understand
there's an efficient way to do it but
that was great Packman you're out i
still love them still I love him even
more pat your great vegan who uses the
Keurig you're smart and efficient Dave
you could learn something from this guy
love you guys Shalom ok yeah so Pat
you've brought in a little something
right this is my home coffee apparatus
you just put some of the ground coffee
in here right that way you don't have to
waste the pods Pat is holding up for
people who don't know what he's talking
about he's holding up a reusable Keurig
pod so you're not constantly throwing
them out you just fill it with coffee
put it in the machine and Pat is not
wasting plastic everybody that's what he
wants to tell you okay on the bonus show
today SpaceX has made their big
announcement I will tell you what it is
we also found out about when an oil
giant knew that what they were doing was
a danger in terms of the climate and
also we are going to talk about if
Donald Trump's claims that media are
falsely reporting things about him or
correct where are the corrections where
are the corrections from Trump on the
bonus show today david pakman.com slash
membership sign up coupon code i voted
17 gets you a huge discount tremendous
really